Jay let me bring up let me play a clip
from you from the panel because you
brought up the other major issue that we
haven't talked about too much here which
is that the censorship machine that was
silencing guys like you or or virtually
anyone that was outside a mainstream
group think on this uh kind of went all
the way up to the top big Tech
government etc etc take a look I think
the centrally important issue that
caused the problems is that we silenced
people
from expressing their thinking
qualified people from expressing their
thinking and as a result the decision
making at the top of the of the of the
country was absolutely abysmal Jay I
suspect you agree with that guy
well first of all I should have comb my
hair my mom had Mom that's another thing
um yeah I think uh I I think that that
that's that that science you know it
doesn't work unless you're unless you
have freedom
you know you you have scientific
cultures that try to sort of mimic
science like I I like I think like what
happened to science in the Soviet Union
you had one man
lysenko who's decided that mendelian
genetics was wrong and then I'm like
contributing on your area Brett um and
then and then um and then like he throws
all of the mendelian geneticists into
Siberia and a huge generation of of of
of of uh Russians starve because of the
stupid science that they're doing right
but as well as in science so if he was
playing at science science can only
happen and can only occur when there
isn't that censorship because who
controls it it's going to be the
powerful people that control the sensor
who control what you can or can't say
and it doesn't matter if they're right
or wrong or it just matters that they're
powerful
science needs to have David and Goliath
stories all the time all the time like
it needs to have people at the top being
overthrown in their ideas by the Young
Turk you know mathematician who's like
no Jay you you're you're wrong and then
I'm wrong because it's just that's the
way the what the dividend says
um and and you can't have that unless
you have free speech
Brett bring us home well uh you know I I
hear what you're saying Jay you fix the
incentives you fix the system and I
agree with that but it's a long-term
proposition and the reason is akin to
what happens if you have a let's say you
have a neurotic cat who's afraid of
strangers and it hides under the bed
when strangers come over right how do
you teach the lesson that the strangers
aren't actually a problem because the
cat's always under the bed when the
strangers are there and if you drag the
cat out from under the bed you increase
its Terror so it thinks it's really
hiding from something real you've got an
entire an entire system
populated by people who have now
actually survived because they did
conform and say things that actually
hurt other people so training them that
this is the moment to reverse that
instinct is not going to work over a
short period of time they're going to
have to be replaced and again
the problem is there aren't enough
people left in the system who understand
how science is supposed to work to teach
a new generation right that is that is a
critical problem and it's not one I hear
discussed very frequently